good heavens you've been asking for this
dr. Watson how did you start for your
exhibition doctor the infamous bell pull
from the adventure of the speckled band
search the kingdom come for this what
are you doing here homes what exhibition
this one I suspect this is unforgivable
homes to be a surprise for your Hornet
and 36 birthday I thought you were on a
case not half as interesting as the case
you are presently on Watson and believe
me my friend my intent is not
interference but crime prevention crime
prevention Yes Doctor there are villains
about villains out to destroy your
exhibition right under your very nose
unseen insidious what's the temperate
you're in this room wearing warm about a
marmot careful Watson heat is one of the
villains to which I refer and its
accomplice relative humidity look here
see the lling in that letter the
whopping in this villain and in this
vellum where a a high relative humidity
doctor how can you tell elementary my
good fellow as victims of a low relative
humidity they are new to this
environment notice the embrittlement
textbook the splitting in that vellum
binding the contraction in this
parchment certificate I see perhaps I
should see if there's anything here that
might be a particular risk thank you for
your concern and rest assured that a
constant temperature and relative
humidity will be maintained within a
reasonable range now if you don't mind
out what of that visible seemingly
innocent villain who can wreak total
diss
ruction slowly inexorably over a period
of time you mean light of course
naturally we'll be careful to ventilate
our display cases to avoid heat buildup
from interior illumination excellent but
what of that unseen villainess who fades
colors yellows and weakens fibers that
bio the face of works on paper fabrics
and paintings ultraviolet every
precaution has been taken arms most of
her destructive power is hidden in the
light of the Sun you can draw the blinds
of course all display cases will be kept
out of the direct sunlight I assure you
ah fluorescent lights much less
ultraviolet than daylight Watson but
filtering is still advised it will be
taken care of simply by applying these
ultraviolet screens over the tute good
did you know that tungsten lamps have
the lowest ultraviolet no filter needed
here use those new halogen lamps with
care they can be filtered to eliminate
ultraviolet but they burn even hotter
than the tungsten variety we know all I
won't don't worry avoid undue risk of
killing of damage the exhibition will be
limited to a three-month right but only
three months that's considered the
absolute maximum for safe exhibit e IC
soviet
and many unseen villains looking about
there's one very visible one yes you
live smoking if you please right of
course doctor forgive me particulates in
the air it can be very destructive to
delicate materials not to mention
tobacco stain fingers on precious items
such precious items as good time homes
all in good time now I must complete
this by morning too you'll be so kind as
to Watson what why not drop this charade
and allow me to help you mount this
exhibition well Tempus Fugit and I can
be useful all right but no comments on
my choices I shall be mute
why Jim Watson the only thing you
haven't included here is the giant rat
of Sumatra until show much to tell ours
don't need so much space and patience
our road here is to tempt to provoke to
stimulate not inundate hmm less is more
air well put it's a good thing I
happened by that wasn't too difficult
we've chosen our theme after the fall
and the book selections have been
narrowed down to these four and they
speak volumes of course the Strand where
your overly romanticized narratives of
my exploits were published the covers
the thing here we agreed so we simply
allowed to lie flat hmm studies of pipe
debris will open this one's no excuse me
now this transparent polyester burn we
over help keep the book open and won't
interfere with your readability of your
monograph on tobacco ash yeah now too
tight don't want to damage the paper do
we perish the thought but of what's
supporting the cover huh just a followed
a bit of cardstock nope prevent stress
on the binding excellent idea and your
favorite reference volume propped up at
an angle of no more and 30 degrees huh
so the weight of the pages doesn't cause
the entire volume to say any good yes
and last but not least a copy of one of
your medical journals
open to let the curious know what the
professionals took for medicine in the
late 19th century how do you prop it up
I thought we made with one cradle yes
but I was I was able to fashion another
plastic foam hmm yeah clearly the work
of a gifted surgeon oh how many here
isn't a suitably blank expression but
not a very good likeness otherwise no
attractive mat can't had a board and
held in place with paper forms plus I
trust that board is acid free and won't
damage what it is intended to protect
you were absolutely safe found very well
but this picture is another matter
yes Irene Adler the woman one of a kind
Watson I went to a great deal of trouble
to get this it would be unfortunate to
expose it to possible loss hi here
thought you might feel that lace our
clever Watson a photo of the photo
huh there's not a bit of modern
technology which I found very useful
Lecter aesthetic duplication makes it
possible for me to display both sides of
this letter of mind to you reporting
from Baskerville Hall I copy one side
and place it together with the original
other side in this clear polyester film
folder what from where did you conjure
up this polyester folder oh yeah simply
use the same polyester film we use to
strap the books I folded and creases the
result can be safely pin through the
film only held firmly in place voila
we're making progress doctor but surely
there is something more we can eliminate
this watercolor of Baskerville hall for
example very susceptible to the effects
of light temperature and humidity as a
law works on paper surely we cannot omit
the very scene of the crime homes the
lighting environment or under control
and besides is only for a limited amount
of time right quite right this map of
the moors is much too large Watson I say
we can do about it this electrostatic
enlargement of a section where we found
the Hound of Hell will do a trick
instead splendid we agreed textiles are
very sensitive to light heat and
atmosphere ones yes but the valpo is
critical to your deduction on the
speckled band to make sure that no
sunlight dolls its luster ah but may I
remind you the speckled band problem
occurred before Reichenbach and is
therefore outside the theme damn renames
sir Hugo Baskerville I believe Watson
that is Inspector Lestrade
well a good night's work I'd say we have
too many items left over in three months
of fellow we can do another exhibition
on a different theme that was a lightful
ideas
what song is this love them I believe
you're right kiss Clara Hey well here we
are hmm not many visitors that's too
early I wanted to be here before the
daily opening to the public to do a
little little maintenance man yeah
everything seems to be in good order
despite a tendency to overdo Watson
you're labeling is quite good easy to
read and one doesn't have to be a
detective to see what it refers to oh
dear what does he have it a villain of
world gravity I came prepared for such
eventualities yes it's a necessary to
provide support on the entire length of
book if if necessary I use several
pieces of board pieces left over for
making max thus
now what do you think of that it would
appear to be scales or flakes of some
insect sort hmm the answer is just above
the question huh Stapleton's butterflies
of course good lepidopterists that he
was Stapleton thoroughly treated his
collection to prevent predators but no
one can prevent nature's deterioration
it serve no threat to any of the other
materials and exhibition that we don't
want him a long public or be untidy
doing Watson hmm how many T's in
butterfly Oh possible I proof read those
labels very carefully honed obviously
then some clever fiend has gotten into
the case and inserted the error let's
check the security the locks are working
and undamaged it could only be what do
they call it in this century an inside
job very amusing out no one I repeat no
one is perfect that's why regular
maintenance is so important hello very
strange another another homes there some
terrible mall going on the glass after
we were so careful with temperature and
humidity huh how could this be that is a
mystery easily solved observe
your exhibition doctor has become a
victim of its own success I congratulate
you